the Joe Rogan experience now do you
think that that bad version of identity
politics that I mentioned is a big
problem on the left or not a big problem
I'm curious I think it's certainly a
problem but I think it's a vocal
minority problem that's what I think I
think if you just regular people that
are on the Left that are working jobs
and having families and doing their
hobbies and they just have left-wing
ideas I don't think the vast majority of
them hold those positions I think those
positions are things that people use as
revenue I mean not as revenue but it's
like they get points from it you know
they get points from certain types of
behavior that they support certain types
of thinking that they support and it
lets you know you got woke social
justice points well then we agree yeah I
mean I Jenny I asked because I genuinely
didn't know I mean I've heard you
talking about identity policies and
umber though in terms of college
campuses when you look at like what
happened in Evergreen State yeah Brett
Weinstein it's very disruptive yes and
no I mean I do think that it's
disproportionately a prop I think it's a
small problem like you're saying I think
a lot of the problem exists in the
college campus setting but I mean even
at Boston College you know I had sort of
maybe been incorrectly indoctrinated
into the idea that this was really a
problem everywhere on college campuses
and I had an incident the details of
which wouldn't be appropriate to talk
about but with a student when I taught
at Boston College that because of the
circumstances and the identities
involved I was ready for it to go into
this is going to be resolved the wrong
way on the basis of the toxic identity
politics I'm hearing is existing on
college walk this is and it was not it
was the exact opposite so I think the
same way that when you look at Yelp
reviews people who had a bad experience
are way more likely to go and write
about it yes these individual stories
get way more attention than the
percentage of the problem that they
represent I I believe you're probably
correct about that but when you see
videos like Nick Christakis getting just
shouted down at Yale by a group of
students and that the support of the
students and that
shet you say well it is real it does
exist it's real it exists I think that
sensible people on the left like me call
it out but I want to be careful imagine
that you had someone from Cato on the
show which is sort of like a traditional
conservative or American Enterprise
Institute maybe is like a better example
and a lot of the conversation was about
getting them to talk about or denounce
the alt-right for example hmm yeah I'm
sure they would do it but how much
should a EEI denounce the outright when
that's like a different thing that
that's a good example yeah it's a very
good analogy yeah I think we oftentimes
are responding to this very vocal
minority yes and those are the people
that are most invested in getting these
ideas pushed through and they're there
it's also people that you know for a
lack of a better term they're probably
mentally ill and I only mean mentally
ill in terms of like have like
legitimate diseases but in terms of
their thought patterns
they're probably obsessive I mean I've
had friends that were especially friends
that were heavily involved in this kind
of stuff before and it was very damaging
to their mental health this type of
stuff being politics being woke
left-wing shout out at people attacked
people politics okay but I mean you
realize somewhere on the one and then
one of them my friend Jamie kill Steen
was they turned on him and then you know
devastated his life and he realized
along the way like oh Jesus Christ like
what was I doing like I was checking my
Twitter every five seconds and insulting
people left and right and attacking
people just to get everybody say yeah go
get them and you know it's showing
everybody how woke I am and how
progressive I am and it becomes a weird
sort of a point system like you're
trying to score points you're trying to
gain favor with your party there's a lot
of that I think it's really important
though so there's people on the left and
right who get pulled into political
wellness whether it's I'm now tea party
in 2010 people get sucked into Tea Party
on the right and Tifa whatever these are
all groups with different sort of
followings they're not all the same
whatever yeah I do think that there is a
difference between getting extremely
passionate about the idea that everybody
should have ax
- just basic health care then getting
extremely passionate about the idea that
we need to go out of our way to shut
down every abortion clinic in the
country I think that there's just
there's a difference so I don't want to
participate in a false equivalency
between well you got very far left and
very far right people and they're the
same and you've got Center left and
center right and they're the same it's
just two sides of the same coin
like obviously I have a perspective that
is based on my politics I'm glad to
debate any of these issues with anybody
who wants to on the merits but I don't
want to make the false equivalency I
mean listen when you look at
anti-defamation league numbers for
example the vast majority of of hate
incidents in the United States are
coming from the right we could talk
about other ways that the left is active
we could talk about what it means or how
things should be categorized but that's
the reality and so I want to make sure I
don't play a false equivalency game my
audience would crush me if I did that
number one but I think it's just wrong
I think it's wrong to do that no I
thanks bear it out I think you're right
there and I also think that these false
equivalency kind of conversations are
they're ridiculous because each
individual conversation about each
individual issue deserves its own
discussion yes and to say what about
this or what about that those what about
isms those are the the death of any real
rational discussion sure they go on
forever
there they go on forever there's no I
mean it's like scroll that this is why
scrolling Twitter endlessly is a problem
because there's really no end you could
always scroll a little to it to the end
right yeah I mean yeah the it's the new
tweets are coming fast it's the same
with a lot of those what's grammars ever
done that just scrolled until their
phone died just charge it wake up in the
morning and just scroll down all day how
long does it take I think you wouldn't
because the new content appears fast
right because the algorithm yeah but you
would still never run out now just keep
going no